smells great how's it look
[Music]
hey what's up guys i know you're dying
to know what that spam and oreo sandwich
tastes like but before we begin quick
shout out to our sponsor today soundcore
soundcore is an audio company endorsed
by grammy-winning
artists and audio engineers so we're
really excited to be sharing with you
their life q30 noise cancelling
headphones
sorry for yelling i think i have these
on yes i do have these on but anyways
i'm loving these headphones soundcore
these are actually really awesome
headphones they last up to 40 hours in
noise cancelling mode and
60 hours in standard listening mode and
with just five minutes of charging time
you can get four hours of listening time
and what's really cool is that they have
three modes of listening there's an
indoor
an outdoor in a transport mode and
obviously i'm in indoor mode
since i'm inside and even though the
noise cancelling the music quality has a
great
full-bodied sound with excellent clarity
soundcore even gave us a blue headphone
for me
and gave tiff a pink one a perfect
hidden hers to celebrate valentine's day
try to guess what i'm saying right now
come give me a kiss
come suck my kiss because that's the
name of the song i'm listening to
my kiss yeah my
is that what you said come give me a
kiss
okay okay one more one more you are so
beautiful
[Music]
you are so beautiful beautiful
you are so beautiful yeah yeah
so anyways the soundcore life 230 is a
great and affordable option for active
noise cancelling headphones so check
them out in our link down below and
here's our spam oreo sandwich video
all right what's up guys today me and
isaac here are
going to recreate a mcdonald's creation
and this mcdonald's creation it was
released in china
on just kidding news we actually did a
article on this sandwich that mcdonald's
released and it is the spam and oreo
burger what are your thoughts on the
spam and oreo burger seems very odd
it doesn't seem like it goes well
together i mean
oreos a cookie yeah and then spam
i don't know spam does do you like spam
by itself
no what about the spam musubis
yeah so spam is okay then
yeah okay just like how i don't like
mayo in general
funny you say mayo because there's mayo
in the sandwich too but we don't have to
add mayo do you like oreos
yeah okay so you generally do like the
items within the sandwich
yeah generally but then when you combine
it together just kind of like
yo that's weird yeah kind of like
nutella on a pizza
but yeah so today we're gonna try and
recreate this sandwich because it's been
on my mind ever since we reported it on
jk news and i've actually seen a lot of
other people recreate it
i'm just dying to know what that flavor
profile is like i'm a big fan of just
eating things just to know what flavors
are and i gotta try this oreo spam
sandwich so
we're gonna do that today first up we
got
some buns and in the pictures they use
sesame seed buns
the spam and today we're using the 25
less sodium spam just because it's i
think it's healthier
yeah we got the infamous oreos end of
the sandwich
and uh mayo is there an expiration date
on this thing
january 22nd of 21
meaning by like a couple of days
yeah no discoloration first thing
i guess is what do we do what are the
instructions for this thing i don't know
how to make this thing
all right buttons probably come later
oreo is the topping so it comes later
spam is the main thing we'll expand
first ready
you
[Music]
i watch so many cooking videos online
and every chef
likes to smell ingredients when as
you're cooking especially
french chests they like smell the fresh
cream
and then they're just like going in on
like just sniffing everything i'm scared
of spam
why because it does this noise no
because of the one
the smoothie challenge that happened
like years ago
i had it like i made a smoothie and it
had spam in it
and i tasted the spam specifically i'm
still scarred from that
[Music]
would you like some spam that probably
smells like cat food jam it does
it smells like what it's that tin flavor
so now we are going to start cooking the
spam
bam we have our spam and isaac
is now going to work on the oreo
oh man i love oreos how do you eat your
oreos i just eat it normally
i mean sometimes like when i was younger
i just rip it and then just eat the
flavoring and then
yeah oh my gosh nice
[Music]
i have to eat this real quick oh man i
had a clean twist
[Music]
this oreo sandwich i mean or spam oreo
sandwich contains
two slices of spam per sandwich i'm
gonna make one for me one for isaac and
one for tiff to try
so that would be how many slices of spam
isaac
six six oh yeah
you really like that smell huh
all right you were just watching a tick
tock yeah i just wanted a tick tock it
was a relatable one
so whenever there's like a a birthday
party we're all in the jumper and
there's always that one person who ends
up turning it off and we're all trying
to get out
is it fun that sounds fun it's fun
thanks sushra you know what a sous chef
is
yeah yeah kosher yeah like a co-manager
or a assistant manager damn
ready to make a mcflurry with that
forget the sandwich let's make my
flurries i don't want to make something
savory
yeah sweet and savory i just want to be
you're not curious you're not like
i gotta find out what this tastes like
no you're like no i don't wanna
i don't wanna try this at all
[Music]
very nice so a little backstory in the
sandwich
if you didn't get to watch that jk news
episode mcdonald's china came out with a
sandwich that was
comprised of spam and oreo and
mayonnaise in a bun
they only released it for one day in
december i believe
and in that one day they sold 400 000
sandwiches and
that's exactly the number of sandwiches
they had prepped for that one particular
day
and they sold out they sold out within
hours and apparently i guess it's a hit
because everyone
in the news outlets are reporting that
people liked it there was a surprising
combination of flavors there was like a
clash of flavors that people really
enjoyed and there was like a
you know the crunch of the oreo it was a
nice texture thing too so i'm like that
makes zero sense to me but let's try it
man
yeah let's try it here's our plate we're
gonna add some buns now i should have
toasted the buns all right
one for you one for me and one
from mama are you ready for this yeah
okay
spam one spam two
it does smell really good in here though
i like the smell of cooked spam how
about that
yeah i like that i like the cook smells
smelly cooked spam is okay smell of raw
spam
i did not like i did no likey all right
how much should we put
mints mayonnaise man-made
a lot okay so that's mine that's my mess
that's yours
all right and then now take a handful
and just sprinkle some on top i guess
oh yeah that looks delicious so
delicious
what are we doing what is this i'm not
quite sure if
it looks more like a dessert or more
like a sandwich it looks more like a
monstrosity than
anything frankenstein of a sandwich
called the frankenstein sandwich
and then the final touches
tiff you want to come down for a
surprise we got you a present
how many of us here in this family is
gonna like the sandwich you think
only one me yeah
it smells great how does it look
remember this from jk news yeah
salmon oreo salmon oreo
sold out in within a day
i put mayo in there oh you wouldn't you
didn't want mayo yours isaacs didn't
have mayo i'm born apple teeth everyone
all right moment of truth is this more
nerve-wracking than uh
one chip challenge would you rather do
this for the first time or a one-chip
challenge for a second time
the this you rather do this yeah one
chip challenge was terrible
oh how do people do this without
reacting oh my gosh
i don't blame you i should do whatever
you got to do
we stopped recording before like the
worst parts of that challenge happened
actually
yeah my stomach started to hurt i was
nauseous when i fell asleep
and i woke up the next day i was good
worst part though wasn't it going down
and wasn't it coming out the worst part
is when i was just kind of
trying to figure out which way i wanted
to go inside your stomach that was the
most painful i'm glad i
i was not participating in that one i
can imagine me and you haggling for the
milk
oh yeah all right cheers
[Music]
is it good that's just funny
i didn't trade it oh hey who cheered
what you're that guy you're that guy
that's like oh one two three and doesn't
do it
um i don't know if i would ever
crave for this thing i just taste the
spam maybe yeah like i kind of want more
oreo in this
the oreo is giving it a crunchy
chocolate it's not bad
it's not bad i was expecting throw up
flavor
like the kind of flavor that makes me
kind of want to gag but it's not
doing that for me just doing that for me
you want to just put it out
yeah yeah oh yeah the camera doesn't see
it it's pretty gross ever since that
oreo
i mean the milkshake challenge i had
milk and then cereal it was all going
good
and then i had to add spam you know out
of all the challenges
that we've ever done with you from when
you were little to now that was the one
challenge that you were the one that
wanted to do
yeah like out of all the challenges like
no other challenge did you ever
recommend well
one chip challenge not a bunch of
challenges you guys no you wanted spicy
spicy noodle you wanted yeah you wanted
the smoothie challenge was like
your thing total regrets yeah spam is
really salty
it is this is 25 less sodium too yeah
i'm not a fan
i don't want more of the oreo it's good
yeah
i like how your immediate reaction was
just laughter
what made you laugh because i thought i
would hate it i thought i wouldn't like
it i'm actually really enjoying it and
surprisingly it
surprisingly works it does it's actually
working i'm quitting with flurry
we're cutting up all these oreos just
cut up more make
yes we do have ice cream mm-hmm how do
we make them with flurry
we always have the internet in our
fingertips the same thing too about ice
cream and put
oil yeah and then they have a machine
that stirs all the
ice cream and the oreos together i said
ice cream like oreos and ice cream
at the same time ice cream well now i
feel bad that i wasted this entire
burger that's okay go about wasting it
too
because i i can't eat it it's not
revolting
but revolting is that the word that's
the word right
is the proper way revolting because then
revolting is also like
going against people i don't know i got
confused anyway
your stomach is revolting against you
yeah i don't know
i can't eat it but i don't want to
finish it yeah i'm not sure if i want to
finish it either
spam that's not that's not making me
thirsty he was going crazy for the spam
though yeah
i think i'm good yeah i'm good too just
you know those teenage hormone
cravings that are just weird yeah i'm
totally craving
maybe when you're pregnant maybe that's
another time when people go crazy for
foods
wild foods chew that you're gonna try at
home
uh-huh i wanna recommend if you don't
like spam oh yeah
you have to you have to like spam to do
this and oreo actually
i'm not a really big oreo fan but this
wasn't overpowering
like the oreo just gave it like a little
chocolaty like a hint of chocolate but
it was mainly the texture that was the
role in oreo hair with oreo i can't
speak right now my brain is
me without struggling all throughout
like what am i saying
you guys know what i mean right now yeah
yeah yeah now we are
making mcflurry time you just used your
brand new phone
to search up how to make mcflurry yes
that's ty how do you feel about having a
phone now
it feels nice i've been wanting one for
a long time yeah because all my
friends and people i knew had them true
then i always ask mom like oh when can i
get one
when you're older like when you turn 13.
is it worth the wait it was yeah
nice now we can count on you for
random stuff because if you don't know
how to do you can look it up on your
phone you're basically
a grown-up now such as hey isaac can you
make me a mcflurry
so how do you make uh mcflurry though
how do you make my flurry oh
what'd you find out through the
internets on your phone it's
three scoops of ice cream um this is how
much ice cream you have left so i don't
know
if we're gonna have three scoops but uh
whatever this is plus what
half a cup of milk two tablespoons of
half and half
and one half cup of crushed oreos cool
you got that crushed oreos at all yep
look at that look at what isaac created
look at that mcflurry that looks pretty
good
mcflurry homemade ice cream soup
taste test
exactly like oreo mcfly it's pretty
[Music]
you